Almost Heaven, older Twitch Chat, all these emotes, wondering how the sun's moved on.
Twitch Chat, from those days that are gone, Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel.
Tap a fog champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes, working Dan's game, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
A time when TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine, Twitch emotes, from long ago.
Twitch Chat, from those days that are gone, Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel.
Tap a fog champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes, still hear his bark in the morning hour.
He calls me, his doggy mode reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat, I get a...
Yesterday, yesterday, Twitch emotes, made you feel.
Twitch emotes, Twitch emotes, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
So, wir sind wieder am Start, bin ich ja gerade rechtzeitig, ja?
Nein, nein, nein, Obi, geh weg.
Ne, es ist nicht Obi, es ist mobile.de, was auch immer das ist.
Ich will's eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Geh weg.
Warum hab ich überhaupt Werbung?
Achso, weil ich im Inkognito-Modus bin.
Und warum ist der Werbeblocker im Inkognito-Modus eigentlich aus?
Man weiß es nicht.
Ich hab mir heute nicht viel vorgenommen, das sind einfach nur ein paar Sachen, die mir so eingefallen sind, wo wir heute ein bisschen drüber schwätzen können.
Ähm...
Ich muss grad mal das Overlay wegmachen.
Aber ich hab...
...ein Control.
Das Ding hier nicht auf.
So.
Jetzt.
Leute, wir müssen übrigens mal was testen, ob der Low-Latency-Streaming-Modus noch funktioniert.
Ähm...
Und zwar...
Wir machen das jetzt so.
Also, ich hab ja Low-Latency eingeschaltet schon vor einer Weile, aber irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, Low-Latency ist irgendwie nicht an.
Weil ich seh das auf dem Vorschau-Bildschirm hier auf der anderen Seite bei mir und das ist doch relativ lang.
Oder mein Delay ist einfach nur lahm, weil der alte Rechner...
...alte Rechner...
...Lahm ist.
Ich guck jetzt mal, ob es irgendwie eine Seite gibt mit einer ganz fetten Uhrzeit.
Äh...
Atomuhr.de, was es nicht alles gibt.
So.
Äh.
Das ist ja die größte Fail-Seite ever.
Die Uhr ist grad rückwärts gelaufen.
Ist ja voll für den Arsch.
Ich hab so meine Zweifel, dass das wirklich eine Atomuhr ist, sondern das ist einfach Fake.
Egal.
Gehen wir mal hier da unten nach.
Guck mal bei euch auf die Uhr, ob das passt.
Ungefähr.
Da kann man, glaub ich, ganz sehen, wie gut das Delay ist.
Ja.
Ich hab übrigens keine Ahnung, ob meine Uhrzeit richtig eingestellt ist.
Vier Sekunden.
Naja, gut.
Okay.
Das ist noch Low Latency.
Ja.
Also, sag mal so.
Alles, alles unter zehn Sekunden ist im Prinzip Low Latency, weil HTS ist ja nie dafür ausgelegt
gewesen, super Low Latency zu sein.
Also, für was steht denn HTS?
Nochmal HTMLs, HTTP Streaming oder so, ne?
HTS.
Block.
Alles blocken.
Blocken.
Block.
Brings.
Ist das nicht HTS?
Ich seh was von Apple.
Was auch immer.
HLS, nicht HTS.
Ah, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ah, ja.
Ihr habt recht.
Lull.
Ja.
Ein bisschen die Erdzahn.
Guck mal.
Überlassen wir mal dem Random.
Dem Random Dings.
Was soll das denn?
für Musik kommt, weil es zu laut ist, müsst ihr Bescheid sagen, aber ich glaube, passt ganz gut.
Ach, HLS hieß der Crap, genau. Ja, und das war nie, das war ja nie für Low Latency gedacht,
dass, ähm, Low Latency HLS ist übrigens auch gar nicht so einfach, also umso weniger Latency,
umso höher, umso höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Wild rumbuffert, weil unter der Haube
ist HLS, also das, was Twitch macht, ich kann es euch, ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen,
wo bloß, ich mache jetzt mal meinen eigenen Stream auf, ich glaube, das verwirrt es dann total,
ähm, wenn man jetzt hier mal in die Browser Tools reinguckt, da wird man nämlich sehen,
geh mal weg da unten, wird man nämlich sehen, dass das im Prinzip, na gut, bei Twitch ist es jetzt
ein bisschen scheiße zu sehen, ehrlich gesagt, im Prinzip ist das nichts anderes wie eine Playlist,
die sich live updatet, man sieht, man sieht das auf, man sieht das hier ein bisschen kacke,
ehrlich gesagt, aber im Prinzip ist das, man sieht es hier,
das ist eine ganz normale, äh, Playlist, die sich updatet und die immer den aktuellen Chunk quasi updatet,
so, und wie man das mit Low Latency Streaming macht, ohne dass man irgendwie Special Sachen drumherum baut,
ist ganz einfach, du machst einfach die Segmentlänge runter und die Einträge in der Playlist runter,
also sprich, du sagst einfach in der Playlist, ähm, ich habe jetzt nur noch, anstatt defaultmäßig irgendwie 15
Playlist Einträge, die sich immer updaten, mache ich nur 5 und meine Segmentlänge sind auch bloß noch,
eine Sekunde, und schon, schon bin ich runter auf 5 Sekunden,
ja, und je nachdem, wie sehr ich das verkürze, umso, ja, kürzer wird das Ganze,
ich habe jetzt letztens gesehen, es gibt ein paar neue Techniken, wie man irgendwie
besonders Low Latency Streaming machen kann über HLS, da braucht man aber wohl irgendwie einen,
einen speziell kompilierten Webserver oder sowas, keine Ahnung, im Prinzip ist mir auch wurscht,
weil ich biete ja selbst kein HLS an, interessiert mich aber wieder, wie der Krempe funktioniert, so, ähm,
okay, das haben wir,
Low Latency schon mal abgehakt, es hat, ich bin nämlich aufgeschrieben, dass wir das heute machen müssen,
testen, so, und jetzt sind wir eigentlich fertig mit allem, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe,
weil ich habe heute kein großartiges Thema, ähm, für den, für den Stream, das Einzige, was wir machen müssen, ist,
ich muss mit meinem 3D-Drucker nebenbei mal, ähm, aber das kann auch ohne mich drucken,
ich muss für meinen 3D-Drucker mal ein Gehäuse anschmeißen, und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ich kann auch einfach das, das,
den Gehäuse drucken,
im Stream anschmeißen, während wir irgendwie über Zeug schwätzen, ja, du bekommst H264 von Twitch, allerdings immer nur, äh, ein Segment von einer Sekunde oder so,
und das auch nur, weil es in der Playlist drinsteht, so funktioniert HLS, so, wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal, wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal ein ordentliches Gehäuse raussuchen,
also, ich meine, ich baue das Gehäuse nicht selbst, ich gucke einfach mal, was, was es so gibt, was ist das da, das sieht nicht aus wie ein Gehäuse,
äh, das sieht eher aus wie weggekockt, äh, was ist das, TTGO T-Beam Tracker Enclosure, ja, das klingt doch sowas wie, was ich haben will,
das sieht eher aus wie, wie, wie aus das fünfte Element, so ein Flugtaxi, nicht wie ein Gehäuse, so, gucken wir mal, was, was die hier für Gehäuse haben,
okay, mit Display, das ist gut, weil ich habe auch ein Display dran, so, eigentlich kann es praktisch aus,
Alter, was ist das?
Was ist das für ein Zäpfchen, äh, was genau, wie soll, wie soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Das ist das Gehäuse?
Und, und was genau?
Ach, das ist für die Antenne!
Ja, ja, finde ich auch lustig, das sieht nicht aus wie so ein Zäpfchen irgendwie, aber das ist für das, ach, das ist für die Antenne!
Okay, äh, also, für was das Gehäuse ist hier?
Das da.
Für das Teil ist das Gehäuse, das verwende ich als LoRa, äh, Receiver, Gateway, wie auch immer.
Und das sieht, das sieht halt so aus, deswegen sieht das so ein bisschen unförmig aus.
Ja, und so wie ich das jetzt verstehe, ist das hier, ist das hier einfach für die Antenne.
Aber das Gehäuse finde ich eigentlich ganz, ganz hübsch, der hat, der hat ein Loch für einen, für was ist da unten, für was ist da unten das Loch?
Für was ist das Loch da unten?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das könnte man tatsächlich mal dem Drucker hinschmeißen, er soll mal eine Runde drucken.
Hallo, ich möchte gerne drehen.
Äh, ach so, Moment.
Ähm, ich verschiebe das gerade mal auf einen anderen Desktop.
Genau, und während das Ding dann ausdruckt, da können wir über alle möglichen Technik-Krams schwätzen.
Okay, meine Maus möchte nicht mehr.
Jetzt vielleicht wieder?
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Das Gehäuse sieht eigentlich ganz passend aus, ich glaube, das probiere ich einfach mal auszudrucken.
Okay.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, für was unten der, das Loch im Gehäuse drin ist.
Äh, ein Gehäuse mit Antenne, brauche ich ein Netz.
Das ist, das ist mir viel lieber, da guckt dann die Antenne raus.
Ich meine, das Ding liegt unterm Dach, da kommt ja kein, kommt ja keine Feuchtigkeit irgendwie dran.
Da brauche ich nicht so ein komisches Zäpfchen um die Antenne.
Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen das mal, das passt eigentlich ganz gut, weil das hat auch ein Fenster für ein Display.
Und das ist genau so ein Display, wie ich habe.
Was haben die anderen gebaut?
Das, wie gesagt, das sieht aus wie, wie ein Taxi.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Und das da?
Das ist...
Ah, okay, mal, hä?
Äh, die Antenne ist bei mir doch, hä?
Die Antenne ist doch überhaupt nicht an der Stelle.
Die Antenne ist doch hier neben.
Okay, was auch immer, wir nehmen das Gehäuse, passt schon.
So ein Lot.
Ähm.
So.
Oktoprint.
Kamera, ich hab's schon mal aufgemacht.
Ach so, übrigens, warum man nix sieht von der Raspberry-Cam ist,
das Licht ist aus.
Aber, wir werden gleich erleuchtet werden, sobald der Drucker anfängt zu drucken.
Ähm.
So, wir anzippen mal den ganzen Mist.
Also, wenn ihr über irgendwas schwätzen wollt, ist mir vollkommen egal was,
einfach in den Chat schreiben, dann gebe ich meinen Senf zu.
Ich habe heute keinen großartigen Plan.
Und wenn euch nix einfällt, dann werden wir zusammen gleich auf AliExpress und, äh, Banggood-Best-Besser-Seit-Name
bisschen China-Kram einkaufen, weil ich brauche ein paar Sachen.
Ja.
Wer gestern im Stream dabei war, der kann sich ja vielleicht noch daran erinnern, dass ich am Ende so ein bisschen ein Problem hatte.
Hier, ich glaube, ich hab den Source-Code sogar noch auf.
Ähm.
Für meinen Controller.
Mit dem Echo-Sensor dran.
Und das Problem war, irgendwie ruckelt die Ausgabe.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Aber es liegt bestimmt am Visual Studio-Code, dass die Ausgabe ruckelt.
Machen wir mal nochmal neu auf, dann ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt ruckeln weg.
Ah.
Elektron, lull.
Ja, es ruckelt immer noch.
Ähm, das Problem...
Ne, es ruckelt nicht mehr.
Das ist echt, das ist echt Elektron.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Wenn das eine Weile läuft, dann ist es einfach ja schlimmer als Java früher.
Ähm.
Da hatte ich ja das Problem, dass mein Ultraschall-Sensor nicht, äh, mit 3,3 Volt funktioniert.
Und ich, äh, kaufe mir jetzt einfach...
...einfach eine neuere Variante davon, die eben mit 3,3 Volt funktioniert.
Easy.
Okay, ähm, so, dann müssen wir das Ganze einmal slicen lassen.
Slicen.
Und dann kann ich es zum Drucker uploaden.
Und dann kann er in Ruhe drucken, während wir schwätzen.
Max, teuer, was ist billiger 3D-Drucker?
Lohnt es sich mehr zu investieren?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich bin jetzt nicht so der Ultra-3D-Drucker-Profi.
Ich habe mir einen Einsteiger-3D-Drucker gekauft, nämlich den hier.
Das Ding.
Bloß, dass der aktuell noch teurer ist, als Star-Version gekauft habe.
Der kostet, ich habe irgendwie 250 oder so dafür, glaube ich, bezahlt.
Und das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, zwei Monate.
Und...
Also für meine Verhältnisse, also für das, was ich mache, reicht das dicke aus.
Aber ich denke mal, es ist wie bei vielen Sachen, wie gesagt, ich habe keine Erfahrung mit teuren 3D-Druckern.
Aber ich denke mal, dass es wie bei vielen Sachen ist, es ist erstens Open-End.
Und umso besser man sich davon auskennt, umso mehr profitiert man auch von den besseren Sachen.
Also...
Also eine Sache, die zum Beispiel, wo ich ein bisschen neidisch drauf bin, bei den besseren 3D-Druckern ist,
die haben einen automatischen Sensor, der Abstand zwischen Druckbett und Druckkopf misst.
Bei meiner muss ich das manuell machen.
Allerdings ist es kein Akt, das machst du einmal manuell und dann ist es eigentlich gut.
Ich habe es aber auch noch nicht perfekt gelevelt, wie das so schön heißt.
Sag mal, was ist mit meiner Maus los? Warum kann ich das jetzt nicht drehen?
Ah, jetzt geht's. Okay.
So.
Äh, Open Files, Files, Case, Full, ich lade mal alle Sachen kurz, mal gucken.
Okay, also, das, ähm, dieses, das komische Zäpfchen kommt auf jeden Fall weg.
Und dann hat er das und das.
Wo ist denn da der Unterschied?
Ach, das ist alles in einem, okay.
Können wir auch ruhig das nehmen.
So.
Dann werden wir den jetzt mal...
...drucken lassen.
Ich habe schon eine Weile her jetzt, schon ein paar Wochen her, wo ich das gemacht habe.
Man musste dem doch irgendwo sagen...
Lay?
Nein.
Äh, Reset?
Oder passt das so?
Mal gucken, wie lange er jetzt drucken würde.
Vier Stunden nach dem Fisch.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ähm, ich mache mal kurz den Deckel weg.
Ich glaube, wir drucken die Dinger einfach mal einzeln.
Wir drucken, wir drucken die Dinger mal einzeln.
Ich glaube, viel zu lange.
Case.
Case würde dauern.
Drei Stunden...
Warum dauert das denn?
Ach du Scheiße, warum ist das...
Da brauchst du auch kein Infill großartig.
So ein Port brauchst du ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht bei.
Ach, für die Wand.
Die Wand, die macht es mit 20% Infill wahrscheinlich auch.
Ähm...
Sir of Jelly.
Ich wollte mir ursprünglich auch einen Pusa 3D Drucker kaufen.
Wahrscheinlich spricht man das Prusa oder so aus.
Das kommt, glaube ich, aus Polen.
Ähm, die waren aber die Lieferzeit...
Extrem hoch.
Das waren so drei Monate Lieferzeit.
Und dann habe ich trotzdem bestellt.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, ich kann nicht bezahlen.
Weil...
Warum konnte ich nicht bezahlen?
Genau, weil es irgendwie über 1000 Euro gekostet hat.
Und ich anscheinend...
Habe ich mir zu diesem Zeitpunkt...
Wusste ich das überhaupt nicht, dass das der Fall ist.
Dass ich wohl bloß bis 1000 Euro über meine Kreditkarte bezahlen darf.
Und Paypal hatten sie für Deutschland nicht angeboten.
Und, ähm...
Danach habe ich mir gedacht, komm, bestellst du dir...
Dann bestellst du dir jetzt einen bisschen günstigeren Drucker.
Und als ich jetzt den günstigeren Drucker bestellt bin,
bin ich damit eigentlich auch zufrieden.
Und habe gesagt, ja, lass mal canceln.
Wie viel kostet das Druckmaterial etwa für das Case?
Keine Ahnung, paar Cent.
Ich habe jetzt schon ein paar Sachen gedruckt für meinen Technik-Krams.
Und ich habe immer noch den größten Teil der Rolle, die dabei ist.
Also der Hype-Drucker schlechthin für Einsteiger
ist ja zur Zeit der Ender 3.
Weißt du das Ding?
Weißt du das Ding, glaube ich?
Da gibt es ja, ist das Internet ja voll mit.
So.
Ähm.
Save to File, bla, bla.
Wir gucken einfach, ob das Ganze...
Wie sieht es eigentlich ohne Support aus?
Da brauchen wir doch eigentlich kein Support für.
Vielleicht für die Dinger hier ein bisschen.
Vielleicht für die Schrauben oder so.
Wofür brauchen wir bei dem Case Support?
Das ist doch eigentlich ziemlich...
Ziemlich viereckig.
Was auch immer.
Ich probiere es einfach mal zu drucken.
Mal gucken, was rauskommt.
Und da können wir uns bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich mal meinen LED-Mod in Anführungszeichen
vom 3D-Drucker angucken.
Aber das wird nun nicht gespoilert.
Das muss man sich dann live in der Cam angucken.
Achso!
Ha, ich habe den Drucker gar nicht an.
Drucker nochmal einschalten, aber erstmal hier File uploaden.
Äh.
Fuck.
So.
Anycubic hat die gleiche Qualität und kostet die Hälfte.
Ich kann es schlecht beurteilen.
Ähm.
Ich weiß nur, dass man beim Anycubic ein bisschen mehr manuell machen muss, aber da habe ich
eigentlich keine Schmerzen mit.
Äh.
Crimex, mir geht's gut.
Alle sind...
Alles top.
Äh.
Was sagst du dazu, dass Ubuntu 32-Bit Multilip kickt und sich Valve und Vine nach alternativen
... Machen sie das?
Warum...
Warum sollten die so bescheuert sein?
Warum sollte man 32-Bit und Multilip kicken?
Da funktioniert kein Vine mehr und ich wette mit dir, dass ganz viele Leute auch so einfach
Vine verwenden unter...
Unter Ubuntu.
Warum sollte man das denn machen?
Das ist total hängen geblieben.
Äh.
Kennst du einen guten Java-Kurs zum Online-Lernen?
Leider nicht.
Da steht ja Secrets.ha.
Ja, eigentlich könnte ich es jetzt zeigen, weil ich habe das WLAN eh wieder gelöscht.
Das war ja nur für den Stream.
Äh.
Wenn man null Ahnung vom Programmieren hat, aber irgendwo anfangen möchte, macht es dann
Sinn mit Java anzufangen und da erstmal die Basics zu lernen.
Sag ich gleich was zu.
Ich mache jetzt erstmal kurz meinen 3D-Drucker an und schmeiß das Drucken an.
Aber das ist eine gute Frage.
Ähm.
Ich muss ja gerade mal gucken, ob ich die richtige Steckdose finde.
Mein Problem ist, ich habe so eine Übersicht über alle unbenutzten Geräte, also über
alle Geräte in meiner Heimautomatisierung, die ich noch keiner Gruppe zugewiesen habe
und da ist die Steckdose für den 3D-Drucker mit drin und ich kann mir immer nicht merken,
welche der sechs Steckdosen die richtige für den 3D-Drucker ist.
Ich glaube die hier.
Ich drücke jetzt einfach mal drauf und gucke mal, was passiert.
Ich hoffe nur, dass der 3D-Drucker jetzt angeht.
Wenn nicht, dann muss ich mal rüber rennen und von Hand auf den Knopf drücken.
Okay, mal gucken, ob er jetzt angegangen ist.
Hä?
Ist er an?
Come on, bruh.
Ha!
Bam!
Ist er an.
Sehr schön.
So, hier ist der Livestream von der 3D-Drucker, also von der Raspberry Cam, die am 3D-Drucker
dran ist.
Noch sieht man nichts.
Ich muss jetzt aber erst mal sagen, ja, das da.
Print.
Hoffentlich funktioniert der Kram.
Ich hoffe, ich habe sauber gemacht das letzte Mal.
Weil es ist immer blöd, wenn man nach dem letzten Druck nicht die Oberfläche vom Drucker
sauber gemacht hat, also das Bett, wo das drauf liegt, dann haftet es manchmal nicht richtig.
Aber das werdet ihr im Stream sehen wahrscheinlich noch.
Wenn es nicht richtig haftet, sieht man das relativ schnell, dann sprüht das Ding Fäden
komplett über den ganzen Drucker.
Das sieht eigentlich lustig aus.
Verbraucht aber unnütz Material und kommt nichts sinnvolles bei raus.
So, übrigens, das Schöne an Octoprint hier in dem Fall ist, also das ist einfach ein
Raspberry angeschlossen an den 3D-Drucker, das Schöne an Octoprint ist, man sieht hier
auch quasi, wie warm er gerade ist.
Jetzt heizt er gerade das Bett auf, zu der Java-Geschichte sage ich gleich was, und danach
heizt er quasi den Druckkopf auf und fängt an zu drucken und dann sieht man hier auch
was auf dem Kamerabild.
Ich hoffe, ich erzähle jetzt kein Mist und das Kamerabild funktioniert noch, weil so komplett
schwarz...
Wisst ihr Leute, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Ich gehe jetzt mal kurz rüber, mache mal kurz Licht an in dem Raum, dann müsste es
hier auf dem Bildschirm hell werden, dann mache ich das Licht wieder aus und ihr sagt
mir, ob man das gesehen hat.
Hat man was gesehen?
Hat man kurz Licht an ausgesehen?
Ne, nichts gesehen, weil ich mich hier gebatet hier.
Hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Können die Ärzte was sagen?
Können die Ärzte noch einen Ticken lauter machen?
Machen...
Ne, insgesamt ein bisschen lauter.
Okay, also, zu der Frage mit Java, wenn man null Ahnung vom Programmieren hat, aber irgendwo
anfangen möchte, macht es dann Sinn, mit Java anzufangen und da erstmal die Basics
zu lernen.
Also, wenn Java was ist...
Ha!
Licht geht an.
Oh, ich habe das Druckbett überhaupt nicht richtig sauber gemacht.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist schlecht.
Das ist ziemlich schlecht.
Das haftet jetzt nicht richtig.
Erzählt euch mal.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch gleich mal den 3D-Drucker-Fail angucken.
Das ist nicht richtig sauber.
Renn rüber, mach schnell sauber.
Ich habe da nicht mal was liegen zu sauber.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, ob das trotzdem haftet.
Was mich wundert ist, warum bewegt sich denn der Druckkopf nicht?
Der sollte sich eigentlich jetzt bewegen, weil das Licht ist angegangen.
Das Licht ist angegangen und sobald das Licht angeht, sollte der sich eigentlich hoch und
runter fahren.
Ja, aber um die Sache mit Java zu beantworten.
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Also, ähm...
Ich muss die Frage nochmal rausholen.
Also, es macht auf jeden Fall Sinn, mit Java die Basics zu lernen, wenn Java irgendwie
was ist, wo du was von hast.
Ansonsten würde ich mit einer anderen Sprache anfangen.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie an der Uni bist und die lernen Java, dann würde ich sagen, ja,
bringt das was, mit Java anzufangen.
Also, irgendwie finde ich, irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Der sollte eigentlich...
Eigentlich sollte sich der Druckkopf bewegen.
Ohje, jetzt.
Jetzt ist es soweit.
Ja.
Ist das nicht nice?
Wie die Kamera...
Oh, scheiße, ist das dreckig.
Ich glaube, ich muss echt nochmal abbrechen.
Mal gucken, an welcher Stelle er anfängt zu drucken.
Ui.
Wir haben irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Ein wenig, äh...
Übertragungsprobleme mit der Kamera, wie es aussieht.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt...
Ja.
Das geht jetzt übrigens auch gleich wieder aus, sobald die Temperatur runter ist.
Ja, also wie gesagt, um nochmal die Sache mit Java hier abzuschließen.
Wenn du irgendwo bist, wo Java gelehrt wird, dann macht es natürlich Sinn, mit Java anzufangen und sich die Basics anzugucken.
An sich, wenn du einfach nur so anfangen willst, würde ich eine andere Sprache empfehlen.
Ja, also als Einstieg ist Python eigentlich so eine wirklich schöne Geschichte.
Das ist eine sehr, wie nennt man das, eine sehr ausdrucksstarke Sprache irgendwie.
Also man kann das sehr schön schreiben alles, ja, es ist sehr sprechend und es gibt sau viele.
Also Python dürfte die beste Sprache sein, wo es aktuell gibt, was Tutorials, Podcasts, Webcasts, Videos, Anleitungen und sowas angeht.
So für die reinen Basics.
Wenn es darum geht, dass es wirklich schnell sein soll, ist es wieder was anderes.
Aber zum Einstieg ist es auf jeden Fall...
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine schöne Sache.
Oder wenn du Webgeschichten machen willst, bleibt dir natürlich nichts anderes übrig, als mit JavaScript und HTML anzufangen.
Wenn es Windows-Sachen sein soll, dann empfehle ich immer, fang mit C-Sharp an, weil es mit Visual Studio eine super kostenlose Idee gibt.
Macht es Sinn, wenn man null Ahnung von Programmieren hat, aber Mathe einem liegt, Informatik zu studieren?
Ja.
Wenn du Mathe magst, ist Informatik für dich nicht verkehrt.
Okay, Steinex.
Das ist ja bescheuert. Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Ubuntu-Leuten wieder los ist.
So, ich bin ziemlich hinten dran im Chat.
Wagt da nicht gespiegelt in dem Ding rechts.
Max Labessia schreibt gerade an der Fachhochschule, haben sie mit C angefangen.
C ist, finde ich, keine schöne Sprache zum Einstieg.
C ist eines der ekligsten Sachen, die es so gibt.
Vor allem, weil man sich halt selbst sehr leicht in den Fuß schießt.
Hast du den Thingiverse-Link für die LEDs an der Düse?
Ja, die kann ich dir raussuchen, klar.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz den Chat abarbeiten.
Kann ich dir raussuchen?
Oh, ja, Kamera ist wieder aus.
Also, sobald das abgekühlt ist, wenn das Ding auf 50 Grad ist, kriege ich das noch nicht ab.
Muss ich mal kurz rüber und das Druckbett sauber machen und dann drucken wir nochmal eine Runde.
Ja, das kann ich dir...
Ich muss das mal kurz raussuchen, was das war.
Wie ist das denn?
Das könnte es gewesen sein.
Ne, das ist es nicht.
Ha, der da ist es.
Der da.
Wobei das auch... Ne, das ist er auch nicht.
Das sieht fast so aus, plus mein Ring hat auf der Seite auch noch was.
Ja, immer schwierig, den Kram wiederzufinden.
Der da ist es.
Ha, jetzt aber.
Der da.
Das ist der richtige Ring.
Ne, das ist auch nicht der richtige.
The fuck?
Da sieht sich auch alles so ähnlich.
Der da.
Das ist der richtige, genau.
Das ist der Ring, den ich... Den hab ich.
Den hab ich genommen.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, weil den kann man direkt neben einclipsen.
Also auf der einen Seite, ich glaube auf der Seite, macht man die Schrauben, die quasi schon im Lüfter innen drin sind,
macht man einfach raus, stöpselt das dazwischen.
Und auf der anderen Seite clips es mehr ein.
Das... Das hält... Hält total easy.
Hast... Äh...
Hey, ich habe eine Frage zu Computer, dann frag.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
Also das ist das Ding, was ich beim Drucker hab mit der LED.
Mit der LED ist dran.
Auch wenn man sagen muss, dass Mathe in der Programmierung selten braucht.
Naja, es kommt drauf an, was man macht, ja.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, was man macht.
Also ich sag mal, ähm...
Wenn's generell ein bisschen mehr...
Lowland...
Lowlevel wird, dann ist es schon nicht schlecht, wenn man so ein paar Basic-Sachen hinkriegt.
Wobei, ja, okay, das stimmt schon.
Das hat jetzt mit dem, was man Mathe im Studium macht, nicht allzu viel zu tun.
Aber es hilft halt unglaublich.
Ähm...
Wenn man so ein bisschen Binary-Logic checkt, wenn man weiß, was ein Left-Shift und ein Right-Shift macht.
Ja, also so Kleinigkeiten, ja.
Und spätestens, wenn man mal versucht, ein paar Sortieralgorithmen selbst zu basteln,
dann ist es doch gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn man da ein bisschen aufgepasst hat.
Und zum Beispiel schon grob abschätzen kann,
wie schnell was ist.
Würdest du nochmal erklären, wie du deine VM laufen lässt?
Welche Version von Manjaro benutzt du?
Auch so SSH zu Raspberry?
Wenn's dir nicht so umschlägt...
Äh...
Ja, kann ich machen.
Das ist...
Ähm...
Du hast ja schon gesagt, das ist Manjaro.
Das ist...
Also installiert haben wir die VM mal vor drei Jahren oder so.
Da gibt's sogar im Archiv, gibt's noch den Stream dazu,
wo wir die VM installiert haben.
Sag mal, kann der Drucker vielleicht mal ein bisschen abkühlen jetzt,
dass ich den Kram abkratzen kann?
Ähm...
Genau, und Manjaro ist ja keine, keine Distribution,
die einfach mal so zweimal, einmal im Jahr eine neue Version kriegt.
Nein, die kriegt er permanent.
Du kriegst ja permanent, kriegst du bei Manjaro neue Sachen.
Du machst einfach ab und zu einen Update und gut ist...
Äh...
Achso, ja.
Vielleicht solltet ihr auch das richtige Passwort eintippen,
dann funktioniert das auch.
Guck, jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwelche Updates,
unabhängig davon, dass es irgendwelche Betriebssystem-Updates gibt.
Also Manjaro ist, ist rolling.
Also sprich, das Ding, äh, updatet sich, äh, wenn's soweit ist.
Ja, da ist ja letztendlich Salatschnellungs drunter und das ist halt einfach mal rolling.
Da kann man nix dagegen machen, ist auch im Prinzip gut.
Der einzige Unterschied zu Manjaro, zu den Repos ist,
die Manjaro-Repos sind meistens so, glaub ich, zwei Wochen hinten dran
und Manjaro hat einen ordentlichen Installer.
Manjaro hat angeblich ein paar Inkompatibilitäten zu User-Repos,
hab ich aber bis jetzt noch nix großartig von.
Gemerkt.
Ähm, welche Version von Manjaro hatten wir abgehakt?
Und, VMware, das ist die neueste VMware-Workstation.
Was ist das, 15 oder so?
Aber da tut's irgendeine VMware-Workstation, ist eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Ja, und SSH zu Raspberry ist auch ziemlich einfach.
Easy.
Ah, ja gut, der ist jetzt grad nicht an.
Kann ich mich auch nicht drauf verbinden.
Aber, mein, Terminal auf, SSH,
Pi, Add, IP-Adresse vom Raspberry.
Fertig.
Äh, was beim Raspberry wichtig ist, wo wir nämlich grad beim Thema sind,
nachdem du die SD-Karte fertig gebrannt hast,
ich weiß, dass es nicht gebrannt heißt,
aber das hat sich irgendwie mittlerweile alles etabliert,
ähm, hier im Streben.
Also, nachdem du deine SD-Karte fertig gebrannt hast,
musst du noch einmal in das Hauptverzeichnis von deiner SD-Karte gehen
und eine Datei anlegen, die SSH heißt.
Nur dann startet der Raspberry mit SSH enabled.
Aber das findest du auch in zigtausend Tutorials im Internet.
Patrick sagt, dass C die schönste Sprache von allen ist.
Ja.
Okay, der hat unterschiedliche Geschmäcker, ne?
Ha!
Ja, ich muss auch clever den Drucker abkratzen.
Okay, äh, Zockersuchten schreibt,
okay, es geht um meinen PC.
Oh, das ist jetzt ein bisschen längeres Comment, da muss ich mal gucken.
Der ist eigentlich abgekühlt mittlerweile.
Ja, ich kann gleich abkratzen gehen.
Also, er schreibt, okay, es geht um meinen PC.
Ich glaube, dass der sehr schlecht ist.
Ich habe den aber geschenkt bekommen.
Dann ist doch schon mal, kann man sich auch nicht, na, egal.
Ähm, ja, den geschenkt bekommen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von den Sachen.
Ich möchte nur vernünftig zocken.
Der ruckelt bei Spielen wie CSGO schon und läuft nicht vernünftig.
Was braucht ihr für Daten?
Wo finde ich diese, damit ihr, äh, ne, das kann ich jetzt im Detail nicht erklären.
Aber wenn du, also wenn du uns in den Chat ungefähr schreiben kannst,
so ungefähr, was in dem Rechner drin ist,
dann können wir dir sagen, äh, ob da drauf CSGO laufen sollte.
Man muss sagen, CSGO läuft eigentlich auf fast allem.
Also, da gehört schon ein bisschen was zu, dass CSGO nicht richtig läuft.
Manjaro-Stream, siehste?
Gibt's hier gleich wieder, gleich wieder Links zum, zum Setup-Stream von, vom, von der VM.
Kann mir jemand eine Schnellwiederholung der Streams der letzten Woche geben?
Naja, also, wir haben, ähm, wir haben mit einem ESP32, haben wir rumgebaut.
Draw.io
Und was wir gebaut haben ist, ja, wo habe ich denn das gespeichert?
Unter anderem, was wir gebastelt haben, ist das da.
Ähm, wir haben einen ESP32 Microcontroller genommen und haben dafür, ähm, für meinen Briefkasten und mein Hoftor was gebastelt,
dass der gucken kann, ob Post da ist, beziehungsweise ob einer in die Tür reinkommt.
Dann überträgt er das Ganze an weiteren ESP und der schickt es dann per WLAN an meine Heimautomatisierung.
Das haben wir zum Beispiel im letzten Stream gemacht.
Ich habe Ubuntu mit Windows im Dualboot.
Kann ich Windows über eine VM aufbauen?
Auf die Ubuntu-Platte in der VM-Ubuntu-Store.
Äh.
Also, das ist so ein Ding, wo ich sagen würde, theoretisch geht das mit Sicherheit.
Praktisch, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, wie man das gescheit einstellt.
Weil, man kann in VM-Ware mittlerweile auch direkt Platten mappen.
Das funktioniert.
Das kann ich dir mal zeigen.
Also, man kann, man kann hier beispielsweise sagen, äh, wo ist denn hier?
Settings, Add, ähm, Harddisk.
Und da konnte man irgendwo, genau, Physical Disk kann man da auswählen.
Aber, ganz ehrlich, ich wäre da vorsichtig.
Ich würde es nicht machen.
Da machst du dir wahrscheinlich mehr kaputt, als dass es, dass es irgendwie was bringt.
Du kannst hier allerdings einfach Windows 10 runterladen und, und nochmal in der VM installieren.
Da spricht ja nichts dagegen.
Da hast du auch eine etwas leichtgewichtigere Installation dann.
Oh, musst du gucken.
Also, ich glaube.
Ist deutlich einfacher.
Du machst dir noch eine Windows-Installation in der VM und ziehst dir einfach die wichtigsten Sachen rüber.
Allerdings, wenn du viele Sachen noch unter Windows brauchst, würde ich mir überlegen, ob du es nicht umgedreht machst.
Windows behältst und darauf eine Linux-VM laufen lässt.
So mache ich es ja letztendlich hier auch.
Weil für mein Video-Zeugs, für ein bisschen, ein bisschen Bild-Krams und für die ganzen Games brauche ich eben Windows.
Geht nicht anders.
Kommst nicht großartig drum herum.
Ähm, es wird unter Linux immer besser, auch dank Valve.
Allerdings.
Ob das wirklich eine Alternative ist, das sehen wir noch nicht.
Und deswegen habe ich Linux einfach in der VM.
So.
Ähm.
Ja, äh, äh, Matt9er08 fragt, was ist deine Meinung zu Ubuntus-Planen, jeglichen Support für 32-Bit-Libraries entfernen?
Finde ich total bescheuert.
Hatten wir es gerade schon von.
Weil es scheint ja auch, das scheint ja auch Wein zu betreffen und, ähm, die ganze, äh, äh, wie hieß es, Multilib-Geschichte, was ziemlich kacke ist, ja.
Ubuntu ist.
Ist eines der meistverbreiteten Systeme, wo die Leute drauf aufsetzen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum man das ausgerechnet jetzt einstellen will.
Das muss ich mal kurz lesen.
Was die da, was die da.
Oh.
Ja, okay.
Ja, wir restarten Firefox.
Wir haben ja gerade ein Paket-Update gemacht.
Dann restarten wir auf Firefox.
Ist gut.
Du darfst ruhig restarten.
Das muss ich nicht selbst machen.
Tja.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ja, ich finde es bescheuert.
Also ausgerechnet jetzt, ja, ausgerechnet jetzt, wo das, wo, wo Games unter Linux ganz passabel langsam anfangen zu funktionieren, dank Valve, jetzt zu sagen, oh, nö, nö, oh, da haben wir jetzt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ich meine, klar, äh, mir persönlich macht es nicht so viel.
Ich verwende weiter Manjaro und wo gut ist.
Aber für alle Einsteiger, äh, schon eine Meinung zu den neuen AMD-CPUs gemacht.
Ja, ich warte mal ab.
Aber ich bin, ich bin echt happy.
Wie das AMD-CPU-mäßig jetzt gerade richtig auf den Putz haut.
Das finde ich, das finde ich sehr, sehr nice.
Finde ich das sehr, sehr nice.
Omega-nice ist das.
Ah, jetzt schreibt der hier, der Zocker sucht einen, äh, also ich habe einen i5-2400 3,1 Gigahertz-Prozessor und ich weiß nicht, also, ähm, die CPU reicht für CSGO.
Da muss ich gar nicht nachgucken, wahrscheinlich locker aus.
CS läuft mit fast allem.
Ähm, es kommt auf die Grafikkarte an, ja.
Wenn du, wenn du nur den, nur die Grafikkarte quasi, die, die, die, die, quasi mit der CPU.
Weiß gar nicht, ob die, ob die, ob das Ding quasi eine, eine, eine, eine GPU mit dabei hat.
Keine Ahnung, bei dieser, gucken wir mal.
i5-2400.
Das Ding eine GPU dabei hat.
Okay, es ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Allerdings, trotzdem würde ich sagen, CS läuft.
CS läuft eigentlich auf so ziemlich allem.
Aber ich glaube, da ist keine, da ist keine Grafikkarte dabei, oder?
Oder ist da eine Grafikkarte dabei?
Ne.
Ähm.
Dann ist die Frage, was du für eine Grafikkarte drin hast.
Ach doch, hier.
Prozessorgrafik.
Steht auch sogar extra fett da.
Äh, okay, das Ding ist natürlich Crap.
Also, wenn du mit der Onboard-Grafikkarte spielst, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass auch CS GO nicht gut läuft.
Allerdings kannst du ja mal.
Ich, wobei.
Also, mit der Onboard-Grafik ist wahrscheinlich alles ein bisschen, ein bisschen, äh, scheiße.
Ich glaube, damit lässt sich nicht, damit lockst du keinen mehr hinterm Ofen vor mit der Onboard-Grafik.
Ähm.
Der General Gunrider fragt.
Hi, kurze Frage.
Welche GUI für Git auf Linux ist dein Favorit?
Gar keine.
Git-Kommandozeile, beste.
Git-GUI kommt mir einst nur in den Weg.
Rainer KWF schreibt ein fuchsiges Hallo.
Dann kann ich ja einfach mal sagen, ein keksiges Hallo.
Also, äh, also Zockersucht, du brauchst auf jeden Fall eine ordentliche Grafikkarte.
Also, ordentlich, ne?
Für CS GO.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was man da, da kann, CS GO kannst du wahrscheinlich nahezu, ne?
Nahezu alles nehmen.
Sofern es nicht von 2011 ist, ja.
Nehm irgendwie irgendeine Mid-Range-Karte.
Ich, ich bin da leider nicht so auf dem Laufenden, was, was Grafikkartenentwicklung angeht.
Ja, und hör mal nicht auf den Sibaro, das ist total übertrieben.
Nicht, dass du das jetzt auch glaubst am Ende.
Was weiß ich, so 1050 oder so.
Für CS reicht eigentlich, gibt's eigentlich schon eine 1050?
Keine Ahnung.
Für CS reicht eigentlich nahezu, nahezu alles irgendwie.
Ein Spiel wie Skyrim.
Skyrim sollte laufen, Skyrim läuft da auch drauf.
Ich mein, Skyrim ist alt.
Skyrim ist von, ist das nicht sogar von 2011?
Ist doch alt.
Ach doch, 2011.
Also deine CPU kommt aus dem gleichen Jahr wie Skyrim.
Ähm, mit irgendwelchen großartigen Mods oder, oder irgendwie diese neue Version wird's wahrscheinlich schwierig werden,
weil Skyrim an sich war, glaub ich, relativ CPU, ähm, intensiv, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab.
Und, ähm, ja, also wenn du das, wenn du dir eine 1060 kaufst, wie der Flo das vorschlägt,
das ist mit, also für CS GO ist das mehr als genug, ja, und für Skyrim reicht das, auch dicke.
Und sie überlegen, Skyrim ist zumindest in der Standardversion, ist ein Game von 2011.
Und auch wenn Skyrim viele Fans hat, man sieht das Game, Skyrim schon an, ja.
Ich hab mich, ich hab ja damals in einem Video gesagt, ähm, dass du Skyrim anmerkst,
dass es noch ursprünglich für die letzte Konsolengeneration mitgekommen ist,
wie, quasi, wie unbelebt und leer die Städte sind und sowas.
Und da kam, ich mein, das ist, find ich, ne relativ objektive Aussage gewesen im Video.
Und ich mein, wenn man das mal mit anderen Sachen vergleicht, mit MMO-Städten oder sowas zum Beispiel,
da sind die Skyrim-Städte, sind schon relativ unbelebt.
Da steht man da was rum, da läuft man was rum, da läuft man eine von zwei Wachen,
aber da ist im Prinzip nicht viel los.
Und, ähm, da waren die Skyrim-Fanboys damals so angepisst, dass ich was, dass ich, dass ich ein, ein,
einen vermeintlichen Negativpunkt von Skyrim angesprochen hab.
Da haben sie sich, da haben sie mich geflamed in einem Video, das weiß ich noch, wo ich mir gedacht hab,
was man sich nicht alles aufregen kann, ne?
Ja, und das Wasser-Sibaro sagt, stimmt schon, 90% der Mods für Skyrim sind Porn-Mods.
Das ist, das ist ganz schlimm.
Ähm, was heißt schlimm?
Ja, also, je nachdem, wer was benutzen will oder nicht.
Und funktioniert die Grabwasser-Anzeige jetzt, fragt der Cheat1995.
Äh, die ist aktuell bei mir noch auf der Terrasse im Testbetrieb.
Was ist mit den neuen Spielen, wie zum Beispiel Battlefield oder so?
Äh, sag ich gleich, achso, ach, naja, also, Battlefield an sich läuft ziemlich gut.
Muss man, also, muss, das muss man wirklich mal sagen.
Die haben mit Battlefield 1 und Battlefield, ähm, 5, haben sie nicht die gleichen technischen Probleme gehabt,
wie es damals bei Battlefield 3 und 4 war.
Battlefield 3 und 4 lief am Anfang mehr schlecht als recht.
Die Spiele, also, jetzt mal rein von der Performance her, lief, laufen die ziemlich gut.
Und Battlefield 5 hat eine unglaublich gute Performance.
Vor allem anbetrachtet dessen, was, ähm, das Ding grafisch, grafisch liefert, ja.
Und, ähm, in der 1060 wärst du auf jeden Fall gewappnet für Battlefield.
Ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie CPU-intensiv Battlefield 5 ist.
Also, da könntest du vielleicht bisschen Probleme kriegen mit einer CPU von 2011.
Wieso heißt Poggas jetzt Poggi?
Ist ne gute Frage.
Bei mir heißt Poggas noch Poggas.
Oder ist das ein Personal-Emoji?
Und ich werde wieder gebetet.
Okay, ähm, was für ein, äh, Tilde, das heißt nicht Tilde, das heißt Tiling,
äh, Window, Tilde wär das Ding.
Tiling-Window, meinst du, das ist E3-WM mit Gaps.
Ah, Gaps.
Gibt's ja auch immer Diskussionen drüber, ob Gaps sinnvoll sind oder nicht.
Ähm, äh, Reinecke, wenn du, ich, wir haben einen Stream gemacht, wo wir das eingerichtet haben.
Es ist gar nicht so viel customised.
Also, im Endeffekt, das Wichtigste,
ist, dass man, ähm, ordentliches Farbsthema im Terminal hat.
Sonst kannst du es eh schon ganz vergessen.
Und das Einzige, was ich hier oben habe, ist, ähm, wie heißt das?
E3, E3 Rust, das da.
E3 Status Rust.
Das ist, was ich hier oben für die Bar verwendet hab.
So, und dass das Ganze durchsichtig ist, brauchst du noch nen Composite Manager.
Und da hab ich hier Comptor im Hintergrund laufen.
Der sorgt dafür, dass das durchsichtig ist.
So, das ist im Prinzip alles.
Würdest du SMB1 auf Windows 10 installieren für Fritzner?
Soll ja ein Sicherheitsrisiko sein.
Hä?
Was ist SMB1?
Ach, du meinst Portokoll-Version, äh, äh, Dings hier.
Puh.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das unter Windows installiert.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man das unter Windows ausschaltet.
Ja.
Ja, Manjaro ist drunter.
Ja, ja, klar, Sebaro.
Äh, ich, ich, ich mach mal kurz meinen 3D-Drucker sauber.
Also, wenn ihr, wenn ihr noch weitere Sachen habt zum Besprechen, dann schießt los.
Ich mach mal kurz den Drucker sauber.
Er wieder da.
So.
Mal gucken, ob der Kram jetzt funktioniert, äh.
Ich glaub, ich mach nochmal ne Runde sauber.
Mit, ähm, ich muss mir ein bisschen Alkohol lösen.
Um den 3D-Drucker mal ordentlich zu putzen.
Sonst schmiert's mir da wie verrückt rum.
So, hab ich irgendwas, hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Äh, äh, wenn, wenn sich mein DSL jeden Tag zwischen 3 Uhr und 3.30 Uhr ein- bis mehrmals neu syncht,
dann hat die Leitung oder das DSL, DSLarm ein Problem, oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaub nicht, dass es in einer Fritzbox liegt.
Naja, äh, äh, ne, Zwang, dreimal, dreimal Zwangstrennung wird am Tag nicht absichtlich gemacht.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Hab ich aber auch.
Deswegen wird die Telekom auch gekündigt.
Das geht mir nämlich echt auf den Sack.
So, ich mach den 3D-Drucker nochmal richtig sauber.
So, meine Güte, ey.
Bis ich das, bis ich die Alkoholflasche gefunden hab, wie ich das jetzt anhört, ey.
Bis ich die Alkoholflasche gefunden hab zum sauber machen, hat gedauert.
Ähm, so, 3D-Drucker sollte jetzt sauber sein.
Jetzt können wir das Ganze nochmal, nochmal drucken lassen.
In der Hoffnung, dass es jetzt ordentlich funktioniert.
Und ich hoffe, ich hab alles weggemacht.
Schauen wir mal.
Drucken.
So, drucken.
Wo ist das Problem?
Okay, ich weiß grad nicht, was er verschmerzt hat.
Okay, was hab ich denn übersehen?
Ähm.
Ja, ja, stimmt.
Äh.
Ja, okay.
Das sieht jetzt schon besser aus, ey.
Das sieht jetzt schon besser aus.
Okay.
Da kann ich, da kann ich, das, das sieht in Ordnung aus jetzt.
Also.
Ähm.
Also, zum, zum Thema, äh, IPv6 und, und NAT.
Gibt Folgendes zu sagen.
Äh, äh, zu IPv6 und DS Lite.
Gibt Folgendes zu sagen. Und zwar, in der Regel hast du dann auch Carrier Crate NAT.
Was bedeutet, dass dein...
Ist ein schönes Bildchen für...
Alles ziemliche Crap-Bilder.
Crap-Bilder.
Dass dein Provider...
Noch mal NAT dazwischen macht.
Das heißt, ähm.
Du kannst auf deinem Router noch so viel Port-Weiterleitung machen, oder sonstwas.
Der Traffic kommt nie bei dir daheim an.
Ja.
Okay, die Bilder sind nicht sonderlich schön, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber, im Prinzip ist dann halt noch mal einen Router vor deinem Router, der noch mal NATtet.
Das heißt, du hast keine Chance...
Das irgendwie durch zu kriegen.
Die Bilder sind alle Mist.
Ja, und deswegen kannst du es auch vergessen. Das liegt nicht an IPsec, das liegt generell an Carrier Crate Nut, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Übrigens, man sieht gleich mehr, sobald es einen Zentimeter weiter oben ist, dann sieht man das ganz gut, weil die LEDs sind so hell und die spiegeln sich im Druckbett.
Aber es scheint jetzt zu funktionieren.
Also, norddeutsche Zocker, Unity Media macht das.
Unity Media, wenn man denen lang genug auf den Sack geht, war ja bei mir auch so, die stellen das um.
Die stellen dich allerdings, also mich haben sie auf einen reinen IPv4-Anschluss wieder umgestellt.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile sind sie sogar in der Lage, einen ordentlichen Dual-Stack zu holen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Carrier Crate Nut ist der größte Bullshit ever, den sie sich ausgedacht haben in den letzten 10 Jahren, was das angeht.
Es gibt natürlich Möglichkeiten, das Ganze zu umgehen.
Wenn du zum Beispiel...
Wenn du einen Server irgendwo stehen hast im Internet, der eine öffentliche IP hat, dann kannst du das da drüber tunneln zum Beispiel.
Aber der weiß, als letzter Schluss ist es nicht.
Ja, und es gibt bestimmt auch mittlerweile irgendwelche Services, mit denen man das gescheit machen kann.
Aber viel sinnvoller wäre es, wenn dein Provider das ordentlich umstellt.
Also, ich musste Unity Media ganz schön lange nerven, dass sie das bei mir umgestellt haben.
Und das hat dann auch nur geholfen, als ich öffentlich auf Twitter geflamed habe.
Und da haben die halt gesehen, oh guck mal.
Sie sehen jetzt irgendwie gerade 20.000 Leute.
Das ist scheiße.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Aber Nut hat doch jeder Router.
Ja, ja, Nut hat jeder Router.
Allerdings hast du Einfluss auf den Router.
Also, naja.
Übrigens ist es eigentlich Blödsinn, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Nut und Router hat nicht zwangsläufig was miteinander zu tun.
Aber ja, in der Regel kann jeder Router auch nutten.
Die Sache ist die, dass bei dem Router, wo der bei dir daheim steht, hast du Zugriff drauf und kannst Ports weiterleiten oder Sachen freigeben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Was du auf dem Router von Unity Media natürlich nicht machen kannst.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Unity Media oder Vodafone dir einfach mal Zugangsdaten für ihren Router gibt und sagt, ja, hier, richte dir mal Portweiterleitung ein.
Der Quai fragt, ich stelle mal eine Frage an, dass welche Geräte benötige ich, wenn ich keine Fritzbox oder einen Router mit integrierter Deckstation nutzen möchte, sondern das getrennt haben möchte, Router und Telefon?
Also, es gibt, es gibt so IPs.
IP-Gateway-Kisten, da kannst du dann dein altes Telefon, deine alte Deck-Basisstation anschließen und VoIP mitmachen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde es auch mit einer Fritzbox machen.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich noch eine Fritzbox davor habe, für diese Deck-Telefon-Geschichte.
Es gibt, auf Amazon gibt es Sachen, die machen das.
Das ist dann, ähm, oh, wie heißen die Dinger?
Es ist nicht Deck, das ist eigentlich verkehrt.
Die Dinger, oh, wie heißt der Kram?
Wie, wie, wie heißt die analoge Leitung nochmal?
Was, Line, äh, ja, A, B, irgendwie so.
Ist alles crap.
Aber ich hab hier irgendwo was, sowas liegen, wartet mal.
Kann ich gucken, wie das heißt?
Ja.
Ich hab hier, ich hab hier sowas.
Ähm, was man braucht von Cranstream ist das.
Ah, okay, die machen auch Telefone.
Ja.
In welche Richtung bräuchtest du, ähm, das ist ein Gateway mit, ähm, Anschlüssen für zwei Telefone.
Also ganz normal, diese alten Analog-Anschlüsse da, ich weiß nicht, wie das, wie, ich hab vergessen, wie das, wie dieser eigentliche Anschluss heißt oder dieser, dieser, dieser Typ, der da dran kommt, ja.
Aber das ganz normale, analoge, kleine, viereckige Kabel mit dem leicht versetzten Stecker kommt da hinten rein.
Und auf der anderen Seite kannst du deinen Netzwerkanschluss machen.
Wenn irgendwas, was VoIP für dich macht, brauchst du natürlich immer noch, ne.
Klar.
Also den Server musst du immer noch einstellen.
Kann man die LEDs am Drucker dunkler machen oder die...
Moment, ich hab, genau, im Chat verrutscht.
Ähm, äh, Moment, mein Chat, mein Chat spackt rum.
Genau, kann man die LEDs am Drucker dunkler machen oder die Cam dunkler, dass man sieht, wo er gerade drückt.
Äh, die, die, die Cam kann man dunkler machen, aber wie gesagt, man sieht es jetzt ja schon langsam.
Sobald es ein Stückchen hoch geht, sieht man es besser.
Die LEDs kann man nicht dimmen.
Die sind direkt am 12-Volt-Anschluss dran.
Da, wo auch der, der Lüfter dran ist.
Das heißt, da kann man nicht allzu viel machen.
Die sind nicht irgendwie großartig gesteuert oder so.
Ähm, man könnte die Raspberry-Kamera nen Ticken, nen Ticken dunkler machen, theoretisch.
Aber da müsste ich jetzt rumfuddeln.
Aber du siehst ja, dass man nix sieht, liegt nicht daran, weil die Kamera so hell ist,
sondern weil sich die LEDs wie verrückt unten auf dem Drucker, auf dem Druckbett spiegeln.
Ah, man sieht doch jetzt schon halbwegs, was er da druckt.
Der Vorteil, bist geschützt gegen DDoS mit so einem DS Lite.
Naja.
Das stimmt so nicht ohne weiteres.
Über IPv6 kann dich eh schon mal jeder, die, also, na gut.
Also, so wirklich gede-dosed werden kann man ja daheim nicht.
So, also die klassische Variante, wie man das, wie man das, äh, kennt.
Da, da brauchst du ja irgendwas, was nach außen hin auf ist.
Was du natürlich machen kannst, sind irgendwelche...
Was ist denn so der Klassiker?
So irgendwelche DNS-Amplifier-Geschichten oder...
Aber...
Also, da hast du eigentlich eh wenig Probleme.
Das ist eher so, und das ist das, was auch die ganzen Stream-Sore, äh, immer Probleme haben.
Gar nicht mehr, dass die Streamer gede-dosed werden, sondern eher der Server, wo der Streamer grad drauf spielt.
Und ja, natürlich, du kannst dann auch, wenn du die IP von ihm hast, ihn trotzdem...
Ja, und Carrier Create NAT dürfte dann wahrscheinlich, bin ich, muss grad mal überlegen...
Auch nicht helfen.
Wenn ICMP reicht, ist es eigentlich...
Wurscht.
Bei Nes nicht, wurscht.
Doch, das, das, tatsächlich, äh, wenn ich so mit darüber Gedanken mache, ähm, zumindest sollte dich DS Lite davor schützen, dass du so ohne weiteres gede-dosed wirst.
Allerdings, es wird daheim eh keiner gede-dosed.
Außer du bist krasser Stream-Sore und, äh, ja, also, selbst da werden es eher, sind es eher die Server, die gede-dosed werden.
Wenn sie den Leuten den Spaß verderben wollen.
Heißt das, der Service-Provider NAT-et dann von einem IPv6 ins normale IPv4?
Richtig.
Du tunnelst deinen kompletten IPv4-Traffic, tunnelst du über deine IPv6-Leitung zum Provider und der Provider schiebt dann quasi IPv4 raus und macht nochmal NAT.
Ja, Flo.
Hast du noch, hast du eigentlich noch die alte Intel-CPU in deinem PC?
Naja, alt, alt ist relativ, ne?
Also, ein, ähm, ein i7-8700 ist jetzt ja nicht so alt.
Und der war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt absolut high-end.
Aber ja, den habe ich immer noch drin, ne?
Ich, ich sehe auch keinen Grund, den irgendwie, äh, rauszumachen.
Und was Neues, wozu?
Mein nächster Rechner mit eh irgendeiner AMD-Kiste.
Allerdings, mit der Grafikkarte und der CPU, das ist nicht so, als würde ich irgendwie großartig...
...mehr Leistung brauchen.
Das reicht immer noch dicke.
Ja, Leute, genau.
RJ11, meinte ich.
F-Stecker, ja.
Was guckst du da meinem 3D-Drucker zu, wie er ein Gehäuse druckt?
Während wir uns über alle möglichen Technik-Sachen unterhalten im Livestream.
Jetzt musst du eine Dimmer-Steuerung für deinen Drucker entwickeln, die man mit ZigBee steuern kann.
In dem Fall wäre es sogar viel einfacher.
Ähm, ich müsste die...
Ich müsste einfach einen Dimmer dazwischen...
...und das ganze Kabel machen.
Ähm, oder aber eben die Sache nicht an den 12V-Anschluss vom Lüfter machen, sondern an den Raspberry, der schon...
Also, nicht direkt an den Raspberry, aber über den Raspberry steuern lassen.
Der Raspberry steht eh...
Also, hier ist ja, hier oben drüber ist ja der, dieser Überbau auf dem 3D-Drucker, wo dann der Druckkopf dranhängt.
Und da oben ist der Raspberry dran gepappt.
Das heißt, ich hätte da eigentlich schon eine Kiste, die LED-Steuerung machen könnte.
Aber wozu?
Man sieht es ja auch so.
Ich finde, es hat so ein bisschen was von so Alien-Entführung, oder?
Irgendwie so UFO-mäßig.
Ja, richtig, Zeitwäsch der YouTube, das habe ich mal gelernt.
Ansonsten kannst du mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf machen.
Da habe ich mal versucht, ähm...
...mehr schlecht als recht zu erklären, was ich eigentlich so mache, den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit.
Was, ich habe kein 6700K?
Ne, ne, 8700K.
Äh, Cheat 1995?
Ich denke mal, ja.
Ich glaube, bei Unity Media hat man irgendeine, eine 10er, 10.0.irgendwas, oder eine 172.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ja, klar, du hast eine private IPv4 dann.
Beim Provider.
Und das Ganze geht über deinen IPv6 getunnelt zu Unity Media zum Beispiel.
Warum AMD?
Weil ich es richtig gut finde, was AMD gerade CPU-mäßig macht.
Und was ich noch viel besser finde, ist, dass Intel jetzt mal ein bisschen was zeigen muss.
Wäre AMD nicht am Start gewesen und hätte jetzt mal CPUs vorgestellt, die quasi mittlerweile Single-Core halbwegs mithalten können
und Kerne mehr haben, vor allem preis-leistungsmäßig, viel mehr haben als Intel, würden wir immer noch rumkrebsen wie vor ein paar Jahren
mit 4-Kernen im i5 und 6-Kernen im High-End.
Wenn überhaupt.
Ansonsten wäre es 4-Kerne überall.
Intel hat sich ja den ganzen Mist...
...übertrieben bezahlen lassen.
Und jetzt sind wir schon bei 8 auf dem Desktop.
Und AMD treibt die ganze Sache ja noch weiter.
Und mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn wir dank AMD auch in den nächsten Jahren standardmäßig 8-16 Kerne in Desktop-Rechnern haben.
Genau.
Äh...
Ayla...
...al-Khalif.
Maxis Head of Git.
Richtig.
Wie ist die Lage?
Wir gucken dem 3D-Drucker beim Drucken zu und schwätzen.
WC2 bashen mit dem Friseur.
Ich glaube, der Friseur spielt kein Bad Company.
Ich weiß, dass er es nicht spielt.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich ihn dazu überredet bekomme.
Du flamest andere für den Scheiß-Code, den sie schreiben.
Ziemlich einfach erklärt.
Ja, unterm Strich...
...ist das nicht verkehrt.
Aber bei weitem nicht alles.
Gibt es den Friseur eigentlich noch irgendwo im Internet?
Ja, gibt es.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Friseur.
Oder das, was der Patrick gerade geschrieben hat.
Twitch.tv
slash iFrisi
Neue Xbox.
Stimmt.
Gibt es eigentlich schon...
...Hardware-Spezifikationen zur neuen Xbox?
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Scarlett, ne?
Ja.
Ja, Artea, gebe ich dir recht.
Ich hoffe auch noch drauf, dass AMD gescheite Grafikkarten rausbringt.
Dass Nvidia mal ein bisschen Konkurrenz wieder kriegt.
Dann pushst du eigentlich das neue Meme-Board, lol.
Ja.
Gestern.
Schützt du eigentlich dein ganzes Technik-Kramzeug irgendwie gegen Blitzeinschläge?
Äh.
Ja, das ist im Haus in Dresden.
Also...
...nicht extra.
Also, das Einzige, wo ich halt ne Überspannungsschutz hab, ist im Serverraum.
Und angeblich haben ja die China-Steckdosen, die wir letztens geflasht haben im Stream zusammen,
haben auch ne Überspannungsschutz.
Wobei...
Naja.
Äh, ähm...
Stats.
Specs.
Nicht Stats.
Alter, der Text ist so dumm, ey.
Nicht das, sondern was die singen.
Ich wär gern Madonnas Dickdarm.
Ja, dann wär ich immer satt.
Das ist...
Oh Gott.
Das ist unglaublich bescheuert.
Ähm...
Da sieht man, aus welcher Zeit das kommt.
Wen juckt heute Madonna noch?
So, ähm...
Schauen wir mal.
Was haben die da für Specs drinne?
So, äh...
Wo?
Specs?
Giftspecs?
Custom Chipsets von AMD.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Da ist AMD tatsächlich gut.
Mit ihrer integrierten Geschichte von Grafik und CPUs.
Das war nicht schon von ungefähr,
dass die das letzte Mal, ähm...
in den Konsolen drinne waren.
Was mich überrascht hat,
dass bei der Switch
es Nvidia ist.
Aber letztendlich ist das auch irgendwie nachvollziehbar,
weil das Ding mobil sein soll.
Und sie hatten ja im Endeffekt schon was sehr ähnliches
im Shield TV
und im Shield Tablet und so drinne.
Wo stehen denn jetzt die Specs?
Hab ich irgendwie...
Wo sind denn die Specs?
Hardware Specs.
Hallo?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Debated.
Gibt's denn wenigstens schon, ähm...
Gibt's denn wenigstens schon Gerüchte?
Microsoft Video nicht bekannt im Jahr,
aber es gibt doch bestimmt Gerüchte.
Geh weg.
Video ist nicht bekannt.
Ich hasse Videos, die man nicht wegmachen kann.
Die Seite scrollt nicht richtig.
Seht ihr's?
Was ist das da oben vor allem auch?
Essliche Seite.
Was ist das?
Oh ne.
PS5 Spec Leak.
Epic Leak. Drops.
Ja, guck mal, was da drin ist.
Das würde mich wirklich interessieren.
Klar, wir wissen die endgültigen Specs nicht,
aber mich würde mal interessieren, was es für Gerüchte gibt.
Also, wo gemerkt?
Das ist nicht irgendwie, äh, ne, nicht legit oder so.
Also, was wird, was wird...
Ah, Moment, das ist...
Xbox.
Okay, also, was haben wir denn drinnen?
Zen 2.
Zen 2?
Was, Zen 1?
Das in der, in der...
In der Xbox One und in der PS4?
Ich kann mir die Bezeichnung nicht mehr mittlerweile merken, ne.
Nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr merken.
Oder ist Zen das, was bei Ryzen drin ist?
Ne, das ist Ryzen. Ergibt ja vom Namen her auch irgendwie Sinn.
Ja.
Aber das ist gerade das, also,
das mit zwölf Kernen mit einem ordentlichen Takt,
das ist das, was AMD gerade richtig gut macht.
Ja, wie hieß der Kram in der Xbox, in der Xbox One?
Das war ja auch AMD.
Aber das ist das, was, was, was AMD aktuell richtig gut macht.
Dass die einfach CPUs bauen,
mit ordentlich vielen Kernen drin,
mit einem ordentlichen Takt,
also die nicht super schlecht sind,
Single-Core oder Single-Thread-Performance,
allerdings richtig gut sind, was, was viele Kerne angeht.
Und die machen das ja wohl relativ clever.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich habe mich nicht allzu weit im Detail mit, mit, mit beschäftigt.
Aber die machen ja gar keine großartigen Spiränzchen.
Aber die, so wie ich, so wie ich das gelesen habe,
ist es ja im Endeffekt so,
dass die mehr oder weniger sinngemäß einfach CPUs zusammenkleben.
Die haben quasi ihre, ihre, ihre Einheiten fertig,
und wenn die sagen, hey, eine, wir wollen jetzt einfach,
einfach acht Kerne haben,
dann pappen sie einfach noch eine zweite Einheit dazu, ja.
Und wenn sie, wenn sie dann zwölf haben wollen,
dann pappen sie noch eine Einheit dazu.
Also pappen ist jetzt ein bisschen zu viel gesagt.
Fügen das irgendwie zusammen.
Die Dinger sollen sich halt richtig gut eignen dafür.
Und man hat ja irgendwie mal,
es gab ja mal so ein Bild von den,
von den kommenden Server-CPUs von AMD.
Das waren ja Riesendinger, ne.
Das waren ja Riesendinger.
Das, das, das war ja,
die waren ja fast, die waren ja fast Handflächen groß, ey.
Also Custom-GPU from AMD.
Ja gut, das wundert mich nicht,
dass das dann alles in einem kommt.
28G.
Okay.
Gut.
500G ist auch gut.
Was soll denn das denn kosten?
Das sieht mir relativ kostspielig aus,
wenn ich mir das hier anschaue.
Zumindest eine Sache,
also gehen wir mal von aus,
dass diese Hardware,
dass diese Hardware-Specs,
ungefähr stimmen.
Gehen wir einfach mal nur von aus.
Ich meine, das ist gar nicht mal so weit hergeholt, denke ich.
Ähm,
es würde auf jeden Fall mal wieder bedeuten,
dass eine Konsolengeneration rauskommt,
die ordentlich bestückt ist.
Weil ich meine, das, was damals getrieben wurde,
bei Xbox, bei Xbox One und, äh,
bei PS4,
die Specs waren ja absolut lächerlich am Start.
Da war ja, da war ja ein, ein, ein, ein,
Popel-PC,
war ja, hat ja ähnliche Specs damals,
wie, äh, Xbox, äh, wie, wie PS4 und Xbox One.
Die haben nämlich umsonst, irgendwie zwei Jahre nach Release gleich nochmal nachgelegt.
Wenn man sich überlegt,
wie unglaublich, äh, wie unglaublich viel Wumms
ne Xbox 360 hatte zum Release,
ne Xbox 360, wann kam die raus, 2005 oder so?
Irgendwie?
Ja, 2005.
Die hatte drei CPUs drinne damals.
Okay, einer war hauptsächlich für Dashboarden so gedacht,
aber zu der damaligen Zeit
hatte man noch
nicht
großartig verbreitet
in jedem Rechner ein Dual-Core und auch kein Dual-
und auch nicht mit,
die, die, die hatten ja sogar relativ viel Takt in der, äh,
in der 360.
Es war aber ein Power-PC damals, wohlgemerkt.
Es war kein normaler
X6, es war damals ein Power-PC.
Also hier, ähm,
ein 2, äh,
ein 3,2 Gigahertz, äh, quasi
Triple-Core, damals in der 360.
Das war vor die, für die damalige Zeit,
war das richtig
brutal, ja, das war richtig schnell.
Und das, was, äh, was Sony damals mit der PS3
gemacht hat, war von dem, was sie leistungsmäßig
drin gesteckt hat, auch ziemlich gut.
Die Leute haben es dann nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt, bis zum Schluss.
Ja, und das sieht mir
jetzt von den Specs her mal so aus, wenn das dann
auch 2020 alles kommt,
ähm, dass das 2020
schon mal
wieder in ähnliche Regionen ist,
wie, ähm, leistungsmäßig
damals eine 360 für ihre Zeit gewesen ist.
Weil, wie gesagt, also die letzte Konsolengeneration
konnte es ja komplett knicken.
Nee, ey,
bis 2020 ist es auch nicht Standard,
dass die Leute 12 Kerne in ihrem Rechner haben,
garantiert nicht.
Okay, Grafikkarte habe ich keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, wie gut
was das Ding bringt.
Also in Anbetracht der Tatsache, wenn das Ding 2020
kommt, dann sollte das mal mindestens
auf dem Niveau von der 2008,
von der, von der 2080 sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was, was
diese GPU hier,
keine Ahnung, kann das, kann das
schlecht einschätzen.
Aber die CPU ist ordentlich,
RAM ist auch mehr als ordentlich.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie sie das machen
bei den RAM-Preisen.
Vor allem DDR6 dürfte,
dürfte teuer sein.
Wahrscheinlich kostet das Ding dann
zu Release wieder 600 Euro.
So, und was, was für PS5
Specs, Leaks, was gibt's denn jetzt?
Okay, gucken wir mal, was es
für Leaks gibt
zu PS5. Video.
Geh weg. Ich will kein Video.
Okay, gibt's nicht so wirklich.
Epic Leak.
Kennt irgendjemand eine ordentliche,
eine ordentliche Quelle für
Leaks? Also, das ist jetzt ein bisschen bescheuert.
Ordentliche Quelle für Leaks. Irgendwas, wo einfach
nur drinnen steht, was man vermutet.
Weil ich mich nicht hier so durch
Ende gab AMD auf der
Wird die PS5
abwärtskompatibel? Ganz ehrlich,
mich würde wundern, wenn nicht.
Also ich gehe ganz, also
ich persönlich gehe ganz fest davon aus,
dass sowohl Xbox
Guard als auch PS5 abwärtskompatibel
werden würden.
Warum sollte man das nicht machen?
Das wäre doch total beknackt, wenn man das jetzt nicht macht.
Bei der letzten Konsolengeneration konnte ich's
verstehen. Ich meine, da ist
360 zu Xbox One bist du
bist du quasi von einem Triple Core
Power PC umgestiegen auf
eine 0815 x86
und
von ihrem komischen PS3
Cell zu auch einem stinknormalen
x86 auf der PS4. Allerdings
der Umstieg jetzt von
PS4 auf PS5 und von
Xbox, ich hoffe
die kürzen das nicht,
die kürzen Xbox Scarlett nicht mit S ab.
Dann blickt keiner mehr durch.
Aber Xbox
und Microsoft mit Benahmung ist auch
immer so eine Sache für sich.
Und
jetzt ist es ja beim Sprung von der
Generation auf die nächste Konsolengeneration
2020, es ist ja immer noch
eine 0815 x86
CPU Drohne und im Prinzip ist das ja
ganz normale PC Hardware, die da
drinnen steckt. Das heißt, warum
sollte man es nicht abwärtskompatibel machen?
Und Microsoft wäre ja doppelt
doof, nicht abwärtskompatibel zu
machen, weil sie so viel Energie
gerade reinstecken, die alten Spiele
quasi fit zu machen,
dass sie auch auf der
Xbox One laufen. Wenn das
nicht abwärtskompatibel sein sollte, wäre das
ja komplett verschenkt gewesen.
Scarlett soll noch gar nicht feiern, ich hab keine Ahnung,
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich finde generell die
Projektnamen bei Microsoft
eigentlich fast durch die Bank weg besser,
als das, was am Ende, wie die
Dinger am Ende benannt werden. Könnt ihr euch noch
dran, wie Kinect hieß in der
Projektphase? Jetzt ohne nachzugucken, wisst
ihr noch, wie Kinect hieß?
Project?
Fand ich viel besserer Name, wie das hieß.
Project, wie hieß das? Weiß nicht, kann sich
noch irgendjemand erinnern? Kinect, das Ding, was heute
keine Sau mehr interessiert?
Fast?
Felix, fast?
Project Natal hieß
das Ganze.
Viel besserer Name, als Kinect. Kinect
ist so ein...
Bäh. Fällt mir nicht.
Und Xbox Scarlett wäre auch ein
schön, ein richtig
rund, wohlklingender Name.
Das wäre einfach... Das hätte was.
Aber so wie ich Microsoft kenne, heißt das Ding
am Ende dann...
Xbox XP.
Ohne Scheiß.
Xbox XP. Das wäre so eine typische
Microsoft-Benahmung, die einfach
Fail ist. Das würde mich nicht
wundern, wenn das Ding so einen absolut bescheuerten Namen
am Ende kriegt. Also ich
finde Xbox Scarlett klingt schön, ja?
Sondern ich hoffe bloß
nicht, sie nennen das Ganze
Xbox S. Weil
dann ist die Verwirrung wieder komplett, komplett
äh...
komplett durch, ne?
Weil das ist ja, glaube ich, die Slim Xbox
One zurzeit. Xbox One S.
Das wäre dann eine Xbox S.
Und das... Also ich glaube, so sehr
verkacken werden sie es nicht.
Ähm, ich könnte
mir allerdings vorstellen...
Lustig. Matt, das Gleiche wollte ich
auch gerade sagen. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen,
dass das Ding einfach Xbox
heißt. Weil es ist ja aktuell im
Trend, dass die Spiele quasi...
dass bei Spielen das irgendwie so halb
rebooted wird. Ich meine, guckt euch das nächste Modern Warfare
an. Das nächste Modern Warfare
heißt ja auch einfach nur
Modern Warfare. Und es gab die letzten...
Need for Speed hatten sie zuletzt oder
Medal of Honor oder... Es gab ja viele Spiele, die
jetzt quasi einfach wieder
heißen wie ein Spiel...
Battlefield 1!
Ähm...
Das nächste Battlefield heißt wahrscheinlich
einfach nur Battlefield dann, oder?
Ähm, also ich hoffe ja
persönlich, dass sie bei Scarlett bleiben.
Weil ich finde, Scarlett ist ein
wirklich... Das ist ein Name, den gibt's
nicht oft. Ähm...
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr...
Wie sagt man so? Unique
irgendwie?
Ähm... Und ich finde, Scarlett
hat...
hat einen schönen Klang für ein Produkt irgendwie.
Aber das finde ich
gut. So, also PS5
Leaks. Ah, hier
hat mir einer ein Leak geschickt. Mal gucken.
Na ja, gut. Wie glaubenswürdig...
Wie, wie, äh...
vertrauenswürdig das jetzt ist, einmal dahingestellt.
Es würde aber passen.
Also, ohne Mist, Leute.
Mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn unterm Strich die neue
Playstation und die neue Xbox
mehr oder weniger die gleiche Hardware drin hätten.
Wieso mehr oder weniger?
Also, das würde mich echt nicht wundern.
Ähm...
So.
Also, was schreibt, was schreibt der denn?
Acht Core... Das wären vier Kerne
weniger. Die Grafikkarte ist auch schlechter.
Bisschen weniger RAM.
Ah...
Also, wie gesagt, mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn die, wenn die... Also, erstens würde
es mich nicht wundern, wenn Microsoft diesmal
ein bisschen die stärkere
Plattform hat. Weil ich mein,
Launch der Xbox One
und der Shitstorm, so nach dem Motto, im Vergleich
zur PS4 damals, das war schon enorm.
Also, die Plöße wird sich Microsoft wahrscheinlich
nicht nochmal geben wollen. Dazu kommt, dass
Microsoft ja jetzt in letzter Zeit eh schon
Xbox eher quasi
so, dass es eher so Xbox
Familie ist. Also, quasi...
Also, nicht für Familie, sondern so nach dem Motto
Games, die dann auch teilweise auf dem PC
laufen und sowas in der Richtung, dass du dann als
Xbox quasi nur noch als, als quasi
Hardware-Einheit kaufst. Und...
Ich denke einfach,
dass Microsoft diesmal nicht wieder
hinterher, hinterher dackeln will, wie
wie beim letzten Release.
Also, ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass
Microsoft diesmal auch ein bisschen in die, in
in die Geld...
in den Geldspeicher greift
und auch
wie gehabt eigentlich,
wie das in der Vergangenheit eigentlich bei den meisten Konsolen
war, drauf legt.
Was die Konsole an sich angeht.
PS3 und Xbox One
waren übelst subventioniert
damals. Vor allem die Xbox
3 und, äh, nicht die Xbox 3.
Die PS3.
Äh, eigentlich ist das
jetzt ja die Xbox 3, wenn man es so will, ne?
Ne, die Xbox 4 wäre
das jetzt.
Äh, Benamungs-Zeugs.
Ähm...
Ja, Sebarro, also die, ich gehe auch stark
davon aus, dass beide Konsolenhersteller
ähm,
drauflegen werden.
Sony hat da richtig krass draufgelegt, damals bei der PS3.
Ähm, und das obwohl
das Ding glaube ich 600 Euro oder so zu Release gekostet hat.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Microsoft
in mein Geldhamse, äh, wirklich
in den Geldspeicher reingreift
und sagt, ey, scheiß drauf.
Ähm, wir subventionieren das Ding
wieder dick.
Und je nachdem, wie sie das machen werden,
also sprich, wenn die Spiele
immer mehr Crossplay wären, also nicht
Crossplay vom Multiplayer her,
sondern immer mehr, ähm,
wie heißt dieses, dieses, dieses,
komisches
Gamingprogramm, was sie da haben.
Ich habe jetzt gerade vergessen, wie es heißt. Also sprich,
dass Spiele immer öfter
sowohl auf der Xbox als auch auf dem
PC laufen werden, ist eh die
Frage,
wenn man ordentlich einen PC hat, sollte man sich da noch einen Xbox
kaufen. Und da macht es noch mehr Sinn,
dass eben eine Xbox
sehr nah an einem aktuellen PC
einfach dran ist. Nämlich für die Leute,
die sich mit PC-Kauf und Sachen nicht beschäftigen
wollen. Allerdings wenn, wenn
die Spiele halt im Hinblick darauf entwickelt
werden, dass sie eben möglichst easy auf
beiden Plattformen laufen sollen, dann tut man
gut da dran, wenn man eben Sachen
macht. Okay, die Xbox
ist unsere Gamingplattform, allerdings ist sie
trotzdem so nah wie möglich an einem
normalen PC dran.
Ähm, übrigens die letzte Konsolengeneration
war der Richt-, war, war,
Hyper-Reinfall.
Ich hab die hier immer noch
neben mir stehen. Ich hab hier den Controller.
Was steht drauf?
Day One!
2013!
Auf dem Xbox-Controller. Day One!
Und was
meint ihr, wie lange ich die anhatte? Ich kann jetzt nicht
gucken. Ich kann jetzt bloß nur mit dem Daumen gepeilt. Was meint ihr,
wie lange ich insgesamt seit Day One
meine Xbox One anhatte?
So ungefähr.
One day?
Ja, ist wahrscheinlich so ungefähr, denke ich nämlich
auch. Wahrscheinlich ein Tag oder so.
Keine Ahnung, 20 Stunden oder so.
Nicht? Nix? Ich hab da drauf nix
gespielt.
Ich hab damit nix gespielt.
Ich hab dafür Battlefield 4
geholt damals, weil's den Metro-DLC
äh, als erstes gab.
Aber ansonsten weiß ich noch nicht mal, ob ich
überhaupt Xbox One-Spiele hab.
Halo 5 hab ich auch nicht durchgespielt, ne?
Äh, PS4 hab ich
ein bisschen länger gespielt.
Das Last of Us Remake hab ich
gespielt, allerdings
äh, lustigerweise nicht direkt auf
der PS4, sondern
von der PS4 gestreamt auf dem PC.
Ist ja kein Ding, steht ja
mehr oder weniger direkt daneben, weil ich keinen Bock hatte, umzustöpseln.
Und mit dem Xbox-Controller.
Ich hab ja so einen Adapter.
Weil ich mit dem PS4-Controller nicht klarkomme.
Da spiel ich immer mit dem Xbox-Controller.
Ähm,
von den Konsolen her
hab ich tatsächlich auf der Switch am meisten gespielt.
Ich hab Breath of the Wild
durchgespielt, zwar nicht 100%,
aber schon, äh, denk ich mal
so 60, 70%,
was bei so einem Spiel viel ist, weil ich mein, das ist
unglaublich groß, ja.
Ähm, und
Super Mario Odyssey.
Leider gibt's ansonsten
auf der Switch nicht viele Sachen,
die mich sonst interessieren, aber
beide Spiele zusammen haben schon
viel mehr
gebracht als, also viel mehr
Spielzeit ausgemacht, als ich
wahrscheinlich auf PS4 und Xbox One
zusammen hab.
Ne Vita hab ich auch noch, Trivolon.
Ich hab mir ja damals ne Vita gekauft, als
die ganz neu war, und ich fand's ja lustig,
Sony immer auf ihrer Pressekonferenz
so nach dem Motto, ja, volles
Commitment, Vita, volles Commitment,
die stehen voll dahinter, ne, das,
ich weiß noch, vor, vor zwei,
drei Jahren oder so, quasi so die letzte Pressekonferenz,
die sie gegeben haben, bevor sie dann gesagt haben,
ey, Vita ist vorbei,
haben sie sich wirklich auf die Bühne gestellt und gesagt,
so nach dem Motto, PlayStation Vita,
immer noch, volles Commitment
auf die Plattform, beste Mobilkonsole,
geilste Sache ever, äh,
und jetzt die PS4-Spiele.
Wo man sich dann auch gedacht hat, Moment,
ihr habt jetzt einfach mal fünf Minuten eingeschoben,
PS Vita beste, und habt nicht ein Spiel gezeigt.
Da war eigentlich,
da war eigentlich schon klar, jetzt vorbei.
Was macht eigentlich mein 3D-Druck?
Der druckt noch. Der druckt
noch. Wie weit ist er denn?
Okay, der druckt schon 46 Minuten.
Und er braucht noch zwei Stunden oder so.
Ist die Belichtung vom
Drucker nicht besser, wenn das Licht im Raum an ist?
Doch, aber in dem Fall, naja, nee, nee, nee,
also, die Belichtung im Raum ist, ist ziemlich
grottig, also das siehst du nicht viel.
Hier siehst du deutlich mehr.
Du musst leider ein bisschen warten, bis er, bis er ein paar
Zentimeter drüber ist, dann siehst du, dann siehst du es
ziemlich gut. Ähm, oder ich,
ich guck echt mal, dass ich die Dinger ein bisschen
dimmen kann, weil das ist schon ganz schön,
ganz schön hell.
Ähm,
aber die Beleuchtung im Raum ist kacke.
Und außerdem geht's automatisch an
und aus. Also
wirklich leistungsstark ist die, also
im Vergleich zu dem, was die anderen Hersteller
haben, ist die Switch natürlich auch
nicht, nicht stark.
Für ein Mobilgerät ist die Switch halt gut.
Da ist ja im Endeffekt das gleiche drin, wie
im, äh, Nvidia,
im Shield Tablet.
Nicht ganz, ich weiß,
aber so vom Kern her.
Wie kriegt ihr eigentlich alle
von den Pressekonferenzen einfach an News gucken?
Ich hab mir übrigens dieses Mal auf der E3,
ich glaube, ich hab mir bis auf ein paar Ausschnitte
von Nintendo, hab ich mir von der
ganzen E3 nichts angeguckt.
Gar nichts.
Und wenn ich so ein paar News lese, es war auch
so gut wie nichts interessantes dabei.
Doch, Death Stranding
hab ich mir angeguckt.
Death Stranding hab ich mir angeguckt und festgestellt, man blickt immer noch
relativ wenig, aber das gehört
da ja zum Programm.
Habe auf Reddit einen Post gesehen,
dass wohl Android jetzt auf der Switch läuft.
Weil du eine Frage der Zeit
bist, dass da einer draufkriegt.
Wie gesagt, das Shield Tablet ist ja von der Hardware
sehr ähnlich und das ist ja ein Android Tablet.
Ja, ich muss mal gucken, wie ich die
LED-Steuerung mache.
Handy plus Controller, ja, es gibt halt keine
ordentlichen Mobile-Spiele.
Also man könnte schon sagen, hey, ein Handy
plus Controller wäre
eine Option, allerdings es gibt
ja kaum ordentliche Mobile-Spiele.
Außerdem glaube ich, dass so eine integrierte
Sache wie die Switch trotzdem seine
Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile einen Browser auf der
Switch?
Es gibt immer noch keinen Browser
für die Switch?
Ist das jetzt den hier ernst, ja?
Hast du nicht, Keanu Reeves?
Doch, den hab ich gesehen.
Den hab ich gesehen, die 3 Minuten für Cyberpunk.
Fallout 76 Battle Royale.
Ist das jetzt ein Witz oder haben die das ernsthaft
vorgestellt?
Das ist G-Bait, oder?
Wirklich?
Das wollen die mich verarschen.
Ernsthaft?
Nein, nicht nein.
Ich hab mich verklickt.
Moment, falsches
Easy Mode.
Battle-Royale-Modus kommt gut an.
Also ich glaube,
wenn das stimmt, dass der Battle-Royale-Modus
gut ankommt, dann aus einem
einzigen Grund, weil der Rest
noch beschissener ist
als das.
Wisst ihr?
Wenn ihr den Scheiß-Modus habt,
allerdings das andere, was man in dem Spiel
machen kann, noch
3x beschissener ist, dann spielt man halt den
Scheiß-Modus.
Aber jetzt ernsthaft.
Die...
Die haben kein Schamgefühl mehr, ey.
Ich muss mir da jetzt
ein Video voll angucken.
Ich will mir nicht das
Pizza-Meat-Video angucken, ich will mir
angucken, ich will mir den Trailer
angucken. Trailer.
Oh.
The Battle-Royale-Experience.
Nuclear Winter.
Moment.
Die Bewertung ist jetzt schon mal ganz toll.
Ich kann doch nicht sagen, dass ich mich
insignen muss.
Was ist hier los?
Warum muss ich mich da
insignen? Ah, geht doch.
Moment, ich muss mir die Ärzte
kurz ausmachen.
Moment, das ist nicht der richtige Trailer.
Oder?
War das der richtige? Ist das der richtige Trailer?
Das ist nicht der richtige Trailer.
Jetzt.
Das ist der richtige Trailer.
Jetzt ist das doch nicht in ihren Ernst, ey.
Ach, da gibt's jetzt
Nukes auf einmal, die sie ja irgendwie im Hauptspiel
abgeschafft haben.
Das ist natürlich
ein super Verkaufsargument. Ich finde einfach
mal random ein Briefcase und blow
mein ganzes Team ab. Ja.
Super. Das macht bestimmt
dem Spiel richtig Spaß, äh, dem Mitspieler
richtig Spaß.
Dass die sich überhaupt noch trauen, vor die Kamera zu setzen,
weil,
mittlerweile musst du ja als Entwickler Angst haben, dass schon
irgendwie, dass
die Fans komplett am Rad drehen
bei dem Game.
Jetzt wo ich das sehe, was ist eigentlich aus
Royal Firestorm geworden?
Ja, ja, ja, alles gut.
Das sieht so dermaßen beschissen
aus. Jawoll,
ich kann mehr Experience unlocken für Adventure
Mode, dass ich den Modus spielen kann, in alle Scheiße
finden. Na gut, wems
gefällt, wems gefällt.
Okay. Was ist, was
ist eigentlich aus Royal
Firestorm geworden?
Ne, hieß das, ne, hieß das nicht Royal Firestorm?
Wie hieß
das? Einfach nur Firestorm.
Was ist da eigentlich draus
geworden?
Das ist ja schon vor zwei Monaten oder so rausgekommen.
Da spielt aber kein Mensch,
oder? Ne, da spielt keiner.
Oh man.
Schlimm.
Ganz schlimm.
Ich hab erst gedacht, ihr wollt mich verarschen,
als ihr gerade gesagt habt, Fallout 76
ähm, Battle Royale, aber
nein, das meinen die wirklich ernst.
Lächerlich, äh.
Meinung zu GOG Galaxy 2?
Ich hab GOG Galaxy 1
vielleicht 15 Minuten offen gehabt, ich kann zu
GOG Galaxy 2 nix sagen.
It just works Parodie, ne.
Wie findest du die neue
Käsereibe von Apple? Oh, ich find die neuen
Apple-Produkte eh ganz grandios.
Am besten find ich ja den, den,
ähm, den 1000 Euro
Stand für nen 6000 Euro Monitor.
Der 6000 Euro Monitor,
oder der 6000-7000 Euro Monitor,
der übrigens noch nicht mal mit nem
Standfuß kommt.
Monitor ohne Ständer, übertreibt das bei
Mac Pro.
Das ist auch so, das,
das ist ja so ne typische Apple-Geschichte,
und das hat den Typ, ihr müsst ja,
wir können uns das mal
zusammen angucken, das hat den Typ auf der Bühne
übelst
irritiert,
übelst irritiert,
als die Leute
nicht, nicht gejubelt haben.
Ja, Leute, wartet mal.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Äh.
Moment. Nicht laut genug.
Ja, 5000 Euro.
Jawoll. Nice.
Okay, die Dinger sind aber echt ganz gut.
Glatzschopper.
Ich hab, Alter, ist das euer Ernst?
Ein fucking Wesermount von
200 Dollar. Aber es geht ja noch schlimmer.
So geil.
Das irritiert den
Typ voll.
Ich find's so geil.
Das irritiert den richtig.
Das ist Apple einfach nicht gewöhnt auf der
Bühne. Die Apple ist
gewöhnt, auf der Bühne zu stehen, und ich
finde jeden Scheiß, den sie ankündigen,
wird einfach gehypt. Wow. Wow.
Ja, ja.
Jeder
Kram, den Apple auf der Bühne
erzählt, wird ja normalerweise des Todes
gehypt. Und diesmal so die Leute so
Was ist das denn hier?
Ernst?
Scamas, ja.
Apple Kreditkarten, das hab ich nicht gesehen.
Was aktuell versucht,
also was mir, war das von Apple?
Ja! Das ist den hier in
der Audi.
So, hier,
das hier,
das ist dieses
Kino,
hier,
kaufen und im nächsten Monat bezahlen.
Als wäre das jetzt was so geiles.
Ne, aber das ist echt der Witz gewesen.
Ist bestimmt vom 1.4.
Nein, das ist vom 3.
Das ist kurz nach der
Die Weihnachtspark-Konferenz da.
Ach stimmt, Matt. Genau, das habe ich doch gelesen.
GOG Galaxy 2.
Die wollen so einen
Meta-Launcher machen.
All your games in one place, so einen Meta-Launcher.
Man muss dazu sagen, das gibt es aber schon.
Das ist bloß nicht so bekannt, wie wenn das
von GOG kommt.
Es gibt schon, wenn ihr mal auf GitHub guckt,
es gibt schon Spiele-Libraries,
die alle Clients verwenden.
Also es gibt Spiele-Libraries.
Mir fällt jetzt der Name nicht ein.
Das da? War das das da?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Das könnte das tatsächlich
gewesen sein. Ja, ich glaube, das ist das.
Also es gibt ja schon so Dinger.
Es gibt ja schon so Dinger im Endeffekt.
Natürlich ist es, wenn das
von GOG kommt, dann noch
ein bisschen bekannt.
Hunter wahrscheinlich.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall der richtige
Ansatz, anstatt noch einen Client
zu machen.
Läuft Windows bei dir in einer VM?
Nee, bei mir ist es umgedreht. Bei mir läuft Linux in einer VM.
Unter Windows gerade.
Achso, was macht eigentlich der 3D-Drucker?
Er druckt.
Er druckt und
es spiegelt sich immer noch so, dass wir gar nicht so genau sehen,
was er da druckt.
Es ruckelt.
Das ist nicht der Drucker, das ist das
Video.
Mit
Harz, ja, das
ist die bisschen teurere
Variante. Diese Reason-Geschichte.
Tommy, ich glaube,
das ist Taktik, dass man
lieber sagt, nein, nein, nein, weil es weniger
klingt.
Hast du schon das neue Windows-Terminal ausprobiert?
Nee, das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt
habe, war das noch zum Selbstkompilieren, da hatte ich
keinen Bock drauf.
Gibt es da jetzt eine Beta von?
Ah,
oh, das kann, wollen wir uns das im
Streben mal angucken, das neue Windows-Terminal?
Da bin ich, da bin ich echt gespannt drauf.
Was druckst du eigentlich im
Gehäuse für meinen LoRa-Gateway?
Das neue Windows-Terminal.
Der App-Store.
Windows-App-Store.
Hast du den geilen
Trailer gesehen? Nee.
Ach, es ist
gerade wieder Bild. Ah, da kann ich wieder schön
viele Webcasts gucken von.
Ja, da, das ist das Terminal
Ne, das ist Werbung
Hallo, Werbung
Weg, weg
Das ist Werbung für die Bahn
Ja, ist mal klar
So ist halt nicht die Realität
Wir gucken uns das mal mit Ton unter Windows an
Ups
Moment
Die Musik dazu
Oh, sogar
Ich hab vergessen, wie der Font heißt
Sogar Dings hier
Fontgedönsunterstützung
Emoji unterstützt
Ja, endlich
Okay, Leute, das müssen wir jetzt installieren
Store
Terminal
Das müssen wir jetzt installieren
Moment, wo kann man es installieren?
Aber da war doch schon noch
In dem Newsartikel eben drin
Now available for download
Windows Store
Jetzt
Open Store
Jetzt hat es schlechte Bewertungen
Warum?
Kann man das nicht installieren ohne den Windows Store?
Einfach einen stinknormalen Installer?
Ja, anscheinend nicht
Okay, herunterladen
Das geht mal wieder nicht
Der Store ist so scheiße
Warum ist der Microsoft Store so scheiße?
Wir gucken, dass er sich irgendwie mal Namen oder so anzeigt
Man weiß ja nie so genau
Zur Kasse gehen
0 Euro für den Store
Jawoll
The fuck
Alter, lass mich den Scheiß doch einfach installieren
Bist du nicht angemeldet?
Nein, natürlich bin ich nicht angemeldet im Store
Aber man muss doch trotzdem was installieren können
Ich melde mich jetzt hier auch nicht an
Ich weiß doch nicht mal die Zugangsdaten
Gibt es das nicht irgendwo anders als Download?
Naja, also Leute
Es ist nicht notwendig, sich anzumelden
Manch anderen Mist kann man runterladen
Und außerdem
Wenn es notwendig sein sollte
Sich anzumelden
Dann sollte hier ein scheiß Pop-Up kommen
Und mir sagen
Bitte melden Sie sich an
Um das runterzuladen
Und nicht einfach nichts machen
Ich melde mich hier im Streaming-Rechner nicht an
Das ist mein Xbox-Konto
Da ist das ganze Zeug drauf
Mit echter Adresse
Und allem drinnen
Das melde ich mich hier im Streaming-Account nicht an
Kann man nicht einfach einen Fake-Account machen?
Oder so
Einfach Store neu starten
Ich würde nicht wundern, wenn das tatsächlich funktioniert
Okay, wir versuchen jetzt mal was anderes zu installieren
Spotify Music
Das installieren wir und deinstallieren es gleich wieder
Guck, geht
Achso
Nein, danke
Diese App gehört in
Installieren
Easy
Ach, scheiße
Guck, hier funktioniert es ja auch
So
Terminal
Nach was muss man hier eben nochmal suchen?
Warum ist das eigentlich so kompliziert mittlerweile
Unter Windows was zu installieren?
Man kann hier noch nicht mal drinnen Copy-Pasten
Warum kriege ich Infinite Warfare empfohlen, wenn ich nach Windows Terminal suche?
Leute, wie geht das?
Wie könnt ihr euch denn vorstellen, wie sehr mir das gerade auf den Sack geht, dass das nicht funktioniert?
Ah
Ne
Hallo
Warum war da eben gerade oben ein Button und ist der jetzt weg?
Das Windows-Update
Äh, nö
Hab ich das nicht?
Ja, aber
Leute, es kann doch nicht angehen
Dass das Ding mir keine Fehlermeldung ausgibt und einfach nur der Button nicht funktioniert
Okay, ich müsste wirklich MyUpdate installieren
Na gut, das mache ich jetzt nicht
Außerdem kann ich das nicht on-stream machen
Okay, da gucken wir uns mal ein Video an
Von Windows Terminal
Ja, ja
Das muss ja hochgeladen sein
Quasi heute, ne
Installieren wir es mal
Ja
Hey everyone
Nee, das ist nicht von heute
Hochgeladen heute
Today
Wie, gibt's da
Nix?
This week?
Nee, das ist das Falsche
Warum ist, warum ist irgendwie gerade alles
Ja Leute, das muss man nächsten, nächsten Stream, dass wir uns das angucken
Das krieg ich jetzt nicht hin, wenn ich will
Wenn man, wenn es natürlich erforderlich ist
Was ja ganz logisch ist, ne
Dass man für ein neues Terminal erstmal ein Windows-Update machen muss
Ja, das ist das Falsche
Das ist das, das ist ja
Absolut klar, ja
Die sind halt, die sind clever
Bei Microsoft
Man kann das Terminal auch auf GitHub runterladen
Soweit ich gesehen habe, kann man das nicht auf GitHub runterladen
Sondern nur den
Sourcecode und selbst kompilieren
Und die schreiben ja auch selbst, man muss es, man muss es aus dem Store laden
Ja Leute, ähm, das können wir uns jetzt leider eben streblich angucken
Das gucken wir uns aber nächstens zu, da bin ich nämlich wirklich gespannt, dass das so war, oder?
Das gucken wir uns aber nächsten Stream an, da bin ich nämlich wirklich gespannt, dass das so ist, oder?
drauf. Ich weiß, dass mein Bild zu alt ist. Nein, es gibt es nicht zum Download auf Github.
Weiß ich doch. Da, guck. Nur Source Code zum Download. Es ist aber schon witzig, dass
man überhaupt für einen Terminal die neuste Windows Version braucht. Ich meine, warum?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Wie kann man das selbst kompilieren? Ich glaube, das
wollen wir nicht. Ist das UWP? Also, normalerweise würde ich sagen, ja, bestimmt. Allerdings
habe ich mittlerweile festgestellt, Microsoft scheißt selbst zunehmend auf UWP. Aber, das
sieht schon mal ein bisschen nach UWP aus. Wie ist denn die Ordnerstruktur von diesem
Projekt hier? Windows Terminal, Windows Konsolos, Command & Share, Build a new Terminal. I
build a...
Ja, haben die da keine Anleitung, wie man, wie man, wie man, wie man kompiliert? You must
run with... Achso, das habe ich ja nicht. Das hatte ich doch nicht, oder? Außerdem, warum
merkt sich das nicht, wo ich zuletzt drauf gehörte? Store. Ach, jetzt kriege ich gar
kein Call of Duty mehr angezeigt. Hier sind die Build Instructions, okay. Ham... Ja, habe
ich nicht, oder? Habe ich nicht. Ich muss das My Update installieren.
Dann werde ich mal nach dem Stream das My Update installieren. Das wird nicht
kompilieren. Die werden wahrscheinlich im Projekt eingestellt haben, dass UWP-Plattform
sonst wie ist. Also, es ist, wir, wir, aber zumindest haben wir schon rausgekriegt, es
ist tatsächlich ein UWP-Programm. Das nervt mich jetzt echt, dass wir das nicht ausprobieren
können. Ich habe eine Idee. Wir machen uns eine Windows VM. Ja. Das kann ich nicht verwenden
dafür. Platz müsste reichen.
Also, wo gibt es denn das ISO zum Download? Ich brauche das ISO für VMware. Ich will das
Tool nicht runterladen. Wo gibt es, wo gibt es das ISO? Gibt es nur über das Tool? Hä?
Wir laden das jetzt unter, genau, wir laden das jetzt unter Linux runter, dann können